hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the Sun we see this tournament
we already checked how Chucky played
against the program Amanda and then I
said we were gonna cover now even to us
as core above but the game wasn't all
that all that exciting so I decided to
skip that one but it ended in a draw and
this is a game after that one it's a
game from round 8 I wonder lien versus
Sharky so let's check it out really
exciting stuff
we have Knight to f3 Bally and we the
ready opening is on the board we have d6
d4 and Knight to f6 now we have g3 g6
bush up to g2 Bishop to g7 so pretty a
pretty symmetrical stuff with castles by
Lee and castles by Sharky and rook to e1
preparing efore and Knight B to d7
chalky prepares he 5 so we have E 4 E 5
bi bi chalky and Knight to c3 now so all
pretty much normal developing moves
we have b6 and here a lot of moves have
been played in this position
d5 has been played a4 has been played h3
has been played b3 has been played
characters on e5 has been played but
tonight the d5 is a new move so already
as of move 9 we have a completely new
game it is lien that it goes out of
theory Chuckie captures and why not we
have Knight captures pawn captures and
now rook to e8 now with the possibility
of maybe even advancing the pawn further
sometimes in the future and if you
decided to trade everything here then
you're just admitting that you don't
really have anything with white and you
allow black the fully equalized
characters captures you can capture
after capture so you're going to get
characters and it's a it's a it's a
pretty much the same position both
players with the bishop prepare white
will not be able to hope for for any
advantage white dust control a bit more
space due to the D pawn but nothing
nothing spectacular so we have C 3 by
Lee and and now comes a 5 so preventing
Y from further expanding on the Queen
side we have H for preparing h5 and now
Bishop the a6 so keeping his options
flexible in the center and now h5 so
maybe maybe yes maybe not it could be
the influence of alpha zero again but we
do keep seeing h4 h5 in pretty much
every game now he captured some before
with h6 now with an attack on the bishop
rook captures anyone with Czech Queen
captures and Bishop to f6 not allowing
an outpost for the night and g5 we have
a nightcap for Sun d4 and now Knight to
e5 and black can be very happy with it
with his position Bishop to e3 lien
continues development and Queen to d7
now preparing for the other rook to
enter the game we had Knight to c6 now
you either leave this Knight here to be
you know just a monster night or you
capture it so Chuck captures it but it
comes with the cost of advancing this
pawn even further so pawn captures and
c6 but it's not a problem it's very
unlikely that this point will ever cross
at the c7 square so Queen to f5 and rook
to d1 now bringing the rook into the
game Chucky's also does the same rook to
e8 and now Queen to d2 just getting the
Queen out of this nasty e-file we have
Queen to e5 now Chuck it centralizes the
Queen and now you could go for Bishop b4
Queen e7 then retreat Russia back to e3
Queen back to e5 we could see a
repetition here or you could go for
something like Queen to d5 just offer a
queen trade but young Liang isn't
interested in any any repetition he just
goes Queen to c2 he makes room for his
rook to come to d5 and Chuck it moves
the Queen Queen to H the Queen to h5 we
have worked the d5 and now as Chucky
also made room for his rook we have
looked Luke the e5 blocking the attack
Queen to b3 now now if captures captures
the bishop and queen battery will be
attacking the f7 pawn so here came to f8
not allowing our to be in such an
uncomfortable position due to the H
point still being here the King is well
without a free square we have rook
captures on e5 Queen captures on 85 and
now feel free to pause the video and try
to find what lien CAD in mind in this
position while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that when
I said that it's very unlikely that this
point will ever be crossing the c7
square and for those who just want to
enjoy the show it is actually blush of
capture some v6 so what this is
basically you give up a piece for two
points but you also create a path C
Point and now this is a very dangerous
pass bone and also a very fast bone so
here best course of action for Chuck is
just Bishop to c8 once the bishop to see
it is on the board let's a queen b8 now
you have to play Queen EA to give
another pawn with check
Queenie seven the Queen back to be 8 and
now Queen to e6 guarding the bishop and
this should hold however it's a it's a
really disgusting position you cannot
move the bishop we cannot move the king
at the h6 pawn is still here preventing
the King from escaping it did it doesn't
look good even if it's perhaps
manageable by a machine i I don't think
a human could hold this
but chalky doesn't go for this idea
Chuck he goes for Queen to b5 instead he
offers a queen trade but now lien goes
Queen to a7 we have again Bishop to see
it is probably best for Chucky but
turkey goes Bishop to g5 he wants to
eliminate the h6 pawn and then make room
for his King if he can do that he will
probably be okay but c7 is coming now
with the just the threat of Queen b8
check where you will either trade Queens
and you get another Queen into the game
or after check you just move the King
and then you get another Queen into the
game so Queen the c5 now again offering
a queen trade plus attacking the pawn
hoping for characters and captures at
least you can survive maybe it's a it's
a bishops of opposite color so perhaps
it's it's possible but allying is not
interested leaning just goes Queen to b8
check with King Teti 7 and now once
again pause the video and try to find
well the nicest move for white in this
position while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations it's not
only one move there are several good
moves here but whichever you found you
know congratulations and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
Bishop to f1 is possible this trip to h3
is possible simply because it guards the
seed square but the
liyan plate is fastest he just played
Bishop to b7 and it was in this position
unmoved 31 that was silly Manchukuo
resigned the game and a brilliant
victory for young a wonder link which
which gets him one step closer to
winning the tournament and well it it
brings chappy a chalky one step
backwards I don't think it will be
possible for now choppy to win the
tournament but he might be able to get
into the top three so here he resigns
because well c8 is coming you cannot
prevent that there are no tricks there
are no useful checks you can trade but
still there's no way to guard c8y just
gets another Queen into the game and
that's it so really clean and really
instructive after this idea of not just
going for Bishop before just Queen c2
you know going for this pushing the the
Queen back and then just creating a path
bone here really exciting stuff so I do
hope you enjoyed it and I would like to
thank Sanjay sheriff Stefan Miller and
Daniel drayage for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals of
the feeder Grand Prix continuing well
also the coverage of the summer serious
tournament we have to see how that will
end for chalky and everyone and of
course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and also do be a part of the
subscribers video it's going to be
awesome more info about that in the
description below so think oh I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day